peu
[Musique]
allo ah c'est toi c'est à dire j'attends
d'un coup de téléphone de bill et
comment quelle ville tu n'es pas obligé
de connaître tous mes amis que je sache
qu'est ce que ce futur qu'est ce que ça
veut dire encore en amérique donc cette
année verica et alors
non mais qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont fait les
américains ça c'est pas de ma faute si
des parents obligés à apprendre
l'espagnol au lycée pourquoi pas
l'espérer mais je t'écoute que je te
passe les notes du coup de puériculture
mais c'est pour ça que tu me téléphonent
honoré chantal tu es la fin tu vraiment
la fonte font face que j'ai une tête à
l'est au cours du lundi matin
c'est affreux bébé encore des freins
avant ça papa c'est marie chantal qu'il
est de ma vie j'ai tout de même pas lui
raccrocher au nez et les seins steria
seulement papa qu'il est rentré oui
combien de fois ai-je dit et répété que
le téléphone doit être utilisé pour des
communications rapides et pas pour faire
la conversation pendant des heures ouais
c'est le même tarif ne discute pas oui
alors pour en venir aux coups de
puériculture tu as beaucoup manqué ce
matin c'était passionnant on nous a
appris à traquer les bébés de charbon
absolument moi je ne le faire les ongles
qu'est ce que tu dis chew hwee thameur
fait comme d'habitude à l'endroit où tu
sais avec qui tu sais naturellement
la mer je sais pas du tout qu'est ce que
tu racontes
mais non ce marchand tu as tu me
racontes et un truc maman est à la
cuisine naturellement comme d'habitude
encore des histoires avec regina je
préfère pas m'en mêler à yahvé longue
alors à propos là pour en revenir à
cette chose là tu vois ce que je veux
dire oui mais non mais non la personne
en question
non l'autre je te dis l'autre enfin
marie chantal un petit effort quoi la
panne d'essence dans la côte de pochards
ça ne dit pas quelque chose non marie
chantal tu sais très bien que je ne suis
pas seul à faire quoi écoute ça ne tombe
pas si je te j'aime le moins du monde
ils devaient attendre est dehors
maintenant on va pas qu'est ce que tu
vas imaginer je n'imagine rien n'a été
fait de façon d'accueillir son père et
ont de trop sensible pour nous y sommes
cet emploi beerschot et les frais du
coup ne s'entend plus
je vois j'attends je vois je vois la
note à la fin du mois tu te les femmes
aient déjà quand je suis parti ce matin
ça deviendrait s'écrit pas comme ça
marie-chantal tout bout du fil à doite
entendre susceptible comme elle est et
ben voilà on pourrait elle enfin
maintenant je n'ai pas pu continuer
c'est bien moi je veux faire couper le
jeu à 100 pour que vous demandez
d'aurillac est ce que je demande c'est
pas grand chose un peu de calme de
détente déjeuner tranquillement en
famille dès jeudi
je suis découragé complètement déphasé
non vraiment je n'ai pas mérité ça dès
son grand corps à tout ce que j'ai fait
pour être me faire ça moi à 11h45 alors
j'attends du monde
il s'agit de regina s'est encore jamais
dit quelque chose me nommer rien je vais
décider de fermer les yeux sur tout
absolument tout une audi nous disons
maintenant être entendu tout à l'heure
tu l'a traité de tous les noms
un ca pense en partie ma propre fille
enfin explique toi expliqué c'est fini
c'est fini
elle est montée dans sa soeur on a fait
sa valise et voilà c'est fini
encore une qui part au bout de trois
jours de quoi avant douleur qu'est ce
que va penser la concierge un je m'en
fous de la concierge
ça je m'en fous je me fous tu dis dont
la mange la paix pour trouver des
expressions marie-chantal est au bout du
fil
le match commence en avoir sous ce
maillot téléphone et macao soient
gastaud vous tenir à ta fille de
raccrocher immédiatement la ta mère à
raison solange assez bien pas bien pour
le déjeuner nous emmènera tous au
restaurant pour une fois dit tu peux
bien payés à jodie sweetin me dit on pas
de métisses dans sa résidence elle avait
pourtant l'air conteneurs passées
maîtresses wi fi des barrières ont tu
ces questions que tu avance
dangereusement aveugle tu introduirait
n'importe qui dans cette maison un jour
nous finirons tous écorché non moi qui
vais engager voilà que ton égoïsme on
voit la main mais voilà bientôt un tueur
à gages reste ça n'est ce pas et que je
m'appuie tu l'avais seul comme ici à
l'essai pour l'amour du ciel et qu'on
l'écoutera plus rien n'est comme la
levée pure y avait fait défiler une fois
plus ces événements pouvaient jamais
raison à ce que ces grands noms mais
c'est ça mon nom de dieu solange tu vas
jusqu'à paris où fait la valeur ça va
mal je te rappellerai plus tard bye bye
sa peau est possible si encore j'étais
seconde est sûre quand j'étais chez
vendée si si cela je t'ai pas une telle
paresseux mais vraiment qu'elle paraisse
j'étais bien mal élevé ma petite fille
ou mon voilà des histoires pour un
malheureux déjeuner moi je la comprends
regina et lommois la nuit pas sur ce que
les autres allaient rester trois jours
tu trouves pas que ta mère est assez
énervé comme ça on s'en fout je boirai
le calice jusqu'à la lie que la porte on
laisse n'importe quoi cela aucune aucune
importance ce qui peut faire froid dans
cette pièce originale est plus là pour
descendre à cannes
j'irai le chercher chalon qui
recherchent et moi même je le portrait
sur mon dos oui antoine jamais là quand
on a besoin de lui là dix vingt années d
pour se mettre les pieds sous la table
comme d'habitude un petit ton frère ça
te va bien quitter mu en paca le monde
après tout deux personnages et je ne
sais pas la berlue deux disent la même
chose
qu'est ce qui était prévu mais j'ai foi
tu me poses touchés qu'est ce qui était
prévu y avait que ce que j'avais prévu
est prévu un souffle ou fromage des
rognons sauce madère 1 et grand chemise
tu vois quoi un bon déjeuner
s'essoufflait surtout qui m'inquiète le
four est tellement capricieux peut faire
autre chose il me reste une bonne
bouteille de madère pour les rognons ça
irait quand on est grand on vient de
livrer cecco classe parce que moins il y
aura des grands chemise parce que je te
rappelle ma petite maman qui n'est même
pas capable de faire cuire un oeuf à la
coque
là peut-être fait je suis peut-être bon
à rien je suis bonheur je suis vraiment
ya quelqu'un qui est bon à rien c'est
bien je suis bonne affaire moi j'ai
quand même été capable de te faire toi
et fais tu n'as pas eu de fer cuit parce
que c'est comme ça des bougies
débrouillez-vous nous je m'en lave les
mains voilà des années que je me dévoue
dans cette maison mais des années et
total personnes le mène aussi belle
qu'elle devrait m'étendre là sur le
tapis du salon et martial qu'est ce qui
arrive d'abord étudiante est ridicule de
le mettre dans des états pareils
et toi d'où viens-tu zita tard alors de
se mettre à table une fois oui oui et
bien tant mieux ça donnera du courage
parce que déjà il faut le faire et qui
va faire des déjeuners mois mixtes amm
et des affaires le déjeuner et regina
olala ça va j'ai compris dis donc c'est
pas aujourd'hui de nommer gachassin à
quoi tu m'as jamais choisi mon joueur
alors tu viens voilà quelle maison sera
pas d'une minute prend qui puisse cette
idée
aussi mes invités les gachassin comme si
c'était pour mon plaisir
tu sais l'importance de ce déjeuner pour
tes affaires ah bah non non je ne sais
pas justement gachassin est un homme qui
remue beaucoup large beaucoup trop d'où
vient tout cet argent naturellement pas
des cons gagner un peu plus d'argent que
toi ça te semble louche pas après tout
nous ne méconnaissons pas ces gens nous
sortir mon intuition ne mettront jamais
les cachets sont des gens très bien peu
parvenu tout cela comme aux enfants de
nos jours il faut bien une
transformation de la classe sociale a
approché très près pendant mon séjour à
la bourboule des relations de vacances
en deux jours le pignon été fait il
roule voiture chauffeur elle alors
malheur à gaston uniquement à billet par
les maisons de couture joue en gros je
le soir l'arlette de quoi j'avais l'air
avec mes deux chevaux
je vois le genre d'ici et tu sais pas
tout non tu ne sais pas top et c'est là
gachassin
1 pierre l'egypte yala tous aient pitié
mayotte
oui matin à papa dans mon coffre en tout
cas j'en ai jamais vu la couleur
enfin la succession de moments mais
terrain du caire ou quoi c'est pas
laisser dormir tout ça là bas non ah bon
ah bon avant le trafic de devises
maintenant je le fais du site c'est
d'abord sa fille chérie je pense à la
vérité que tu que tu es trop connaître
mac ce n'est pas un reproche que je te
fais mais de nos jours est temps
d'évoluer
on n'a plus la même conception de chou
valeurs actuelles
le citoyen le plus le plus intègre 'on
n'a jamais la conscience tout à fait
nette si ça peut te faire plaisir ma
chère je ne vais pas non plus regarder
même divia
je le regarde tabac je ne veux rien
sabah déclaration
c'est mon affaire il faut bien vivre
comme tu dis d'autant qu'au travail nous
allons nogent franck sont pas prêts de
voler de leurs propres ailes en paye son
corps tout petit coûte bassine pas si
petit que tu aime à le laisser croire
je n'ai rien à l'essai quoi on cherche
les gens me regardent et il faut leur
déduction de même et logiquement on ne
peut être attribué des enfants très
jeunes à une maman qui fait aussi jeune
alors comme tu rajeuni d'année en année
ça risque de devenir inquiétant il est
exact ne s'est pas trouvée ah oui on non
donc ça que c'est pas trés la même pas
commencer à se chercher
alors plutôt que de trouver quelque
chose plutôt qu'elle même j'aimerais
bien que ce soit un mari quant à antoine
mal avec antoine suppose un juste gaz ou
d'un garçon de vingt temps qui passe
séduit dans une cave de la rive gauche
un jouer de la trompette bougea que ça
ressemble ou tu me le dire à présent
qu'ils ont formé un petit orchestre
entre eugène bande de sauvages de
propriété belle fête de la musique le
stade dan mais vous devez comprendre que
naturellement temps est resté à la
méditation de thaïs la twh et
vibratoires ils gagnent très gentiment
son argent à 800 francs par soir et 800
francs par ce choix relatifs mais
j'aurais trouvé une situation autrement
plus intéressante s'il avait été capable
de passer son bachot antoine a pas cent
balles
ben tu sais que tu sais bien que non au
sixième échec il a bien fallu reprendre
son parti
vraiment gaston faut c'est une blessure
qui l'avait son bachot à force de le
dire est essentielle
j'étais tout le monde le croit
bacheliers c'est la même chose même sa
maman le crois pas je n'y ai alors toi
tu as deux qu'il s'agit de ton fils de
madoff haute vous pour le décourager ces
matins tu faisais dans sa chambre et
j'ai vu un projet de publicité pour la
gueule je sais plus quoi mais est donc
tout à fait remarquable pardon il fait
des affiches maintenant vos gosses tout
mais comment vis-tu situe terrible
depuis plus de huit jours
première nouvelle moi ce pas j'en étais
resté à son stage chez gallimard
tu seras l etat les cantons se
l'arracherait à coudre de la revue bon
sens je me demande tu verras tu verras
tu veux pas dire que cela ne m'inquiète
davantage ces petits jeunes gens du
racing et cette bande d'américains
khalfa quand on pense à tout autre chose
qu'au mariage c'est à toi de la
surveiller comme c'est facile ou comme
sue fait du a vu que même maintenant
mais t'as vu comme elle me traite non
mais tu as fait comme une moto c'est
d'ailleurs à bon alors la suite une
faiblesse avec l enclave a pas de
soutirer de l'argent des gueules de
tourner oui on m'en parle pas c'est que
caisse commune me rend malade revient
qu'à partir de ce soir je vais dormir
sur le dimanche
ma chambre et glacial ce matin avant de
me réchauffer j'ai dû jouer trois
disques de malte davis de couteau qui ne
fait rien papa tu connais pas toujours
c'est ridicule comédie du chauffage
mais pourquoi le propriétaire art est il
de chauffer le 15 mars
alors qu'on pêche de froid et sur son
fils en plein hiver alors que d'ailleurs
moi je descends trio mes géraniums ne
sont guère fleurir sur le balcon
logiquement ça devrait être le contraire
ça va changer d'appartement une époque
mais on en trouvait encore à qui dit tu
prêtes à fond peut-être pas une fable
ont pas une fortune jamais voulu quitter
l'appartement où avait vécu d'amères
critiques n'est pas tel parce que
pendant vingt ans le loyer n'a pas coûté
trop cher
enfin voila voila maintenant le
campement drogba michel est au complet
avec jj tas qui va avoir ses petits en
poussant couverte par un danois
t'as pas envie
au lieu de rire comme une petite folle
tu ferais mieux de penser à ta bille et
il serait temps de penser oui quelle
qu'elle soit il vient de mettre comme
europe avec mado que cette somme
éclabousse l'ex étoile est toujours là
alors qu'il va mettre le couvert à etoy
maintenant l'intention de recevoir les
gars c'est d'aller au travail
or mon temps j'ai demandé la concierge
de bien vouloir venir servir le déjeuner
ils postent à tous et je suis là et bien
sûr maintenant j'en avais rêvé copley a
bien livré le [ __ ] en chemise à mes
yeux
dieu merci les dans le frigo justement
il est plus pendant que tu dis j'ai
cherché partout à trouvable ainsi que la
bouteille de madère jamais personne mais
empêche plaisante belge a constaté toi
même il faut que je fasse tout leur
cette maison sans moi
je soupçonne un coup de regina peut-être
vois pas de malheur tu vas entendre ta
mère est dis donc qu'est ce qu'on va
leur donner aux gachassin
j'espère qu'une boîte de sardines dans
la maison oui voilà comme ça je la
traduire en justice les faux l'heure où
les met en prison pour lé grand cheville
la 9e la base enfin cette fille est un
danger public
la dernière bouteille que manière
dilution sporting mais je vais traiter
vin blanc mais pas là il faut se
défendre pour ses traces il faut se
disant absolument contre cette race et
toi c'est tout l'effectif et thé nature
et moi comme un concombre une bonne qui
part en emportant la maison de
saint-girons rien n'y en a pas une
d'intéressant la schlague la sonacc
lâché at elle compris que ça comme ça
dorénavant je fais tout moi-même mais
tout et tout mais surtout qu'ils
préfèrent me tuer au travail plutôt que
d'introduire une de ses soutiens dans
cette maison vraiment je préfère que
l'importance ma santé dans nos
intérieurs
j'en fais le voeu devant vous tout seul
mais naturellement il faut savoir tracer
domestique vive l'amérique
on appuie sur un bouton vous l'avez ça
les fait on a vu une manette le linge à
repasser la veste formidable que tu dis
là est complètement idiot puisqu'il nous
sommes pas dans la même oui et pendant
ce temps là les gachassin se met en
route à funchal et châtaignes cet
incident regrettable mais l'heure tourne
non mais ils sont pas en retard les
invités battu quoi j'aurais plutôt
l'impression que c'est toi qui es pas en
avant ces événements j'ai quelques
excuses sur meu la mi décembre
tu donc à ce tour tu vas faire une chose
mais tu fais un petit peu devenu la
conversation comme c'est égal partir
avec mon [ __ ] non non non bon alors mes
enfants vous voyez pas quelqu'un de vale
ouvrir bon ce n'est alors pas moins avec
notamment vas-y antoine videmment est on
si on leur dit pas visible à ce qui ne
va pas et prépare toi à recevoir un choc
que ce que winne qui est derrière la
porte mais gachassin
non un employé du ciel oh non non il se
trompe sûrement du talent mais qui est
ce c'est une nouvelle donne qui vient se
présenter sans blaster si oui c'est la
concierge qui nous d'enfants oui j'en
fais là il faudrait que ta mère est vrai
mais je me demande si c'est bien
important
après ce langage énergique que nous
venons d'entendre se verra bien on verra
bien
bonjour bonjour suite dans maman tu
revenir une minute on a besoin de toi
abbas m c'est bien drôle je suis trompé
madame va venir tout de suite s'est pas
pressé bah ma fille tu fais affaire
sachant drôle tu t'ouvres pente
oui je me demande ce que ça peut bien
n'être pas c'est mon siret il ya le
caoutchouc près du feu ça dégage
vous avez décidé de m'empêcher de
m'habiller j'avais décidé de m'empêcher
de m'habiller alors que c'est madame la
concierge qui m'envoie à madame elle m'a
dit qu'il y avait un déjeuner à servir
au cinquième gauche et qu'elle pouvait
pas y aller alors comme j'étais libre je
vais me présenter mais vous tombez vous
tombait à pic alors vraiment vous
tombait à pic
mahler tout à fait convenable et je suis
persuadé à l'avant ce que vous ferez
parfaitement la page
non mais j'ai quelques questions à vous
poser bien des fêtes
fait deux en fait
fait pas trop de personnes à servir
combien de personnes un sérieux non non
non et alors à midi nous avons deux
invités mais habituellement nous ne
sommes que quatre tours l'appartement
n'est pas trop grand 5 à oui beaucoup de
bibelots un bon mois jamais vous avertir
tout de suite je casse voilà tous mes
petits bibelots que j'adore
j ai pas tiens non et ce à la la
qu'est-ce que c'est là dans le panier
c'est votre grand mère c'est c'est jj
tassé ma petite chienne alors elles
comptent pas pour un chien en annonces
et moi qui la sort un match pas de chat
non non non non aux canaries haut la
main d'enfant banon me en préparation
l'orage qui est bas alors pour ce qui
est de la nourriture chez au régime
alors grillades légumes montbard et puis
beaucoup de laitages
mais c'est un régime qui vous va très
bien je suis très nerveux alors était
faut que je récupère mon cou ne vous
inquiétez pas notre table et très
copieux et excellent grenat on verra ça
on verra ça
alors pour mes gages double tarif et je
peux vous demander pourquoi mais parce
que je vous dépanne et puis d'enfants
pour l'eau pour l'eau je vois pas devin
c'est une raison c'est une récente oui
effectivement
vous ne pensez pas que vous vous abusez
un peu la situation sada moi il faut que
je gagne ma vie je fais pas de cas
doivent faire moi elle me connaît pas
alors là ça t'apprendra non non non non
jours après je ne voulais surtout pas
vous vexer
et bien c'est accepter c'est accepter
est naturellement vous savez servir un
nom a annoncé j'ai pas bien l'habitude
oui mais ça ne fait rien je vois c'est
avant tout vous êtes cuisinière à non
non non non non ça la cuisine j'aime pas
beaucoup ça me tourner le coeur vous en
aucune importance le déjeuner vrai vous
avez amené votre robe noire à g dames
s'ajoutent les venues comme j'étais sale
and well et un courrier très gai toutes
ses couleurs fini ça ira mais pas
l'attention et faire servir encore blanc
et en livrer les gages
non non non non bon alors voilà
mademoiselle mademoiselle je ne voudrais
pas vous ennuyer
en vous demandant les certificats mais
ça tombe bien j'en ai pas mais je me
poste tu peux vite quand même
mademoiselle je peux vous dire qu'ici
nous n'avons pas l'habitude de changer
de personnel les domestiques faux bond à
ses dires partie de la famille j'aime
que les rapports
l'ama l'air contente la cuisinière
qu'est ce que c'est que ça sur georges
juste alors mademoiselle à la
gentillesse de bien vouloir nous
dépanner comment vous appelez-vous déjà
appel vous allez suivre bal musette
solange à la cuisine elle vous montrera
ce que vous avez à faire c'est par là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez déniché cette bêta
si jamais tout à fait fini oui tu
quelque chose non mais vous l'entendrez
jamais rien tenté
cherry et après on s'étonne que je ne
puisse garder aucune bonne dans cette
maison cette fois nous avons mis la main
sur une perle l'impression tâche elle
une bonne blague a battu tu veux tu te
faisais du mauvais sang bien inutilement
grâce à ce l'enjeu des jeunes est prêt
il ya quelqu'un pour faire le service
tout sera comme d'habitude très réussi
mais pour ne rien négliger pendant que
nous y sommes maman pourra peut-être
nous offrir le luxe d'aller troqué son
peignoir contre une opa oui
j'ai plus qu'à l'enfiler géographie
tellement soit dans cette salle de bains
que j'attends la dernière minute voilà
donc oui bon ben c'est ça alors déposé
ce à quelques pas à faire tomber mon ou
je sais pas moi vous voudrez at-elle
accusé
mon seul reporter on va voudrais savoir
madame la d2 le bronze et écoutent et
écouter metella n'a jamais la nappe toi
bon et alors et puis débarrasser moi ça
voulait vous ménager faut plus des
programmes n'a pas de top
non mais ça demeure pourtant non mais tu
avais gardés chez moi ou c'est vous à la
maîtresse de baies sont bons alors maman
va te dis je prête ma devenu mardi midi
mado m'a dit mardi midi manou maniement
du midi pendant ces neuf quand même
mado oui madame gaza m ad au mahdi el
madénian même un peu trop gras des
partis lundi mardi deuxième jour de la
semaine
12h déjeuner dehors du soleil alors mais
qu'est ce que vous allez à rire comme ça
vous rires temps si quelque chose nous
dit que nous avions deux invités mettez
les deux couverts ou non mais si c'est
pas la peine que je les mette madame et
ils viendront pas
ce qu'elle a dit maintenant ça m'a
échappé mais non mais non qu'est ce que
vous avez dit mais non mais j'ai rien 10
messieurs nous avons très bien entendu
vous prétendiez qu'il était inutile de
bêtes le couvert de nos invités mais
pourquoi et où tu m'intimides quoi la
concierge vous a peut-être donné un
message non mais je sais pas moi vous
avez une amie en service chez madame
gachassin
enfin l'or mais c'est fini même si chez
nous mais non madame non madame votre
attitude est pour le moins bizarre
mattrick ya sûrement quelque chose je
peux pas le dire
m'enfin c'est simagrées expliquez-vous
athènes mais madame voudrais pas me
croire
pourtant c'est vrai je les ai vus mais
enfin vous savez vue qui va mais là ce
monsieur cette dame là vous inviter les
légats chassa les pieds dans l'eau du
cash a les pieds dans l'eau mais oui
monsieur mais vous voulez viendront pas
mais où les saf et vous vivez ou ray
commence à la à tout d'un coup la com
comme ça vous y atteler
je vois je vais vous dire une chose ou
pas l'accord paraît pourtant j'avais
bien tu mettais bien promis de ne pas
dire à madame que je voyais des gens
râlent après tout les ennuis que ce que
ça a tiré non alors même mais même que
c'est pas une tare de jeu mais messi si
je la laisse justement c'est pas de ma
faute c'est une tare vous inquiétez pas
ça s'arrangera non monsieur antoine ça
ça s'arrangera fars je croyais qu'avec
le changement d'air ça s'arrangerait
mais non non non non non peut-être que
j'aille au docteur maintenant c'est pas
une excellente idée tu vois
non c'est pas la nismo crâne mois il
fera comme les gens chez nous là je suis
je racontais à madame joly autrefois de
notre foi ses propres et sûres mais
messi même que j'ai dû changer de
quartier les l'aise les gens voulaient
pas mettre le nez dehors sans que les
gens viennent me poser des questions et
tout ça parce que voilà vance des choses
qui vont arriver à aa
autrement dit vous avez le don de double
combat mental est pas si on qu'on vous
remercier mais n'ont jamais content de
donner une année je suis allé à la
campagne avec mes patrons
c'était dans un château alors un de ces
bleds jeu
le village était à 5 km sur le sol je
vous dis ça c'était pour montrer là le
genre de techno y en avait il y en avait
qui m'appelait la sorcière il ya une
vague projet de la fièvre aphteuse
j'avais jeté un sort
le curé me faisait la gueule ça peut
pourtant être drôlement pratique de
couverts tout deviné amenons non croyez
pas ça parce que si je joue à tout pour
les autres choix rien pour moi
or je perds toutes les clés le parapluie
je gagne jamais à l'abri là je me tire
les cartes ça al'air merveilleux mais
c'est fait c'est toujours en faut et
l'existant bon comme ça me fait quand
même le plaisir de faire votre travail
et vous allez mettre les deux couverts
de monsieur madame d'achat
s'accrochaient à moi je veux bien je
suis dans les pieds dans l'eau puis
allez voir la cause du mal mais un seul
un jabot soigne bien bien mal le père
n'ont pas totalement fermé la porte aux
stages et agir ça c'est bien méchant
assez bien ma chance après après une
voleuse valait que je tombe sur une
démence en quoi pour ça elle m'a l'air
complètement sonné la peau fille
t'imagines le spectacle madame gachassin
couvert de vison et des great en train
de prendre un bain qu'il allait jolie ma
paire tricolore a fait sa vaisselle je
l'appelle la planque à la banque dit ok
ce qu'on aura vu défiler comme phénomène
tu te souviens la bigoudène qui sous la
halle où dentifrice
ce n'est que depuis morissette qui
s'enfermait dans les cabinets pour
pleurer pendant des heures ici c'est la
patate à merveille elle réussit c'est la
pâte à tarte à merveille
non non non et la négresse qui avait
happé la queue jeetah dans l'aspirateur
et al islah bossu qu'on a retrouvés dans
l'île maman avec caceres
on ya cru en freinant le mans ya de quoi
rire toi dès demain je ferme ma maison
et je m'installe à l'automne vous
trouvez ça va moyen de violer quand même
assez de s'engueuler le coeur d'hérault
c'est une ride qu'on n'entend même pas
tenu en bas seulement étonné que je sois
pas pour elle c'est toujours alors
démarrer sur wii
qu'est ce que c'est non la vraie sa
fille qu'est ce vous voulez vous que je
vous la passe pièces seront désolé qui
met bien sûr que j'ai fait la commission
tout de suite car oui oui mais vous
pensez vous madame ils comprendront très
bien oui c'est ça au revoir madame
j'espère vous n'aurez pas trop de dégâts
oui au revoir madame qu'est ce que ça me
gâche à ça et bien ils pourront pas
venir leur appartement à quillan d elle
paraît tellement vite que je regarde
c'est une histoire de baignoires et tu
en crever c'est arrivé juste au moment
où il allait partir et avec tout le mal
que je me suis donné au nom sans me
prendre un tout petit dos on va pouvoir
se régaler en famille
desservie en plus de servir nada
dit adel adèle vous emporterez les deux
couverts bien madame
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ap
qu'est ce que c'est que sa tenue
voila voila l'accoutrement je n'allais
pas faire le ménage en ville
c'est monsieur antoine qui m'a prêté sa
salle de traite
à propos que je n'ai pas encore entrés
sait séduire toujours quoi quand on pose
une question
j'emporte pas arrêter tout instrument je
vous demande si vous l'avez pas vu
madame non mademoiselle n'est pas rentré
qu'est ce que peut bien fait moi qui
rendez-vous à 5
c'est ainsi que du ménage wouah
vous ne pouvez pas faire ça plus tôt
c'est madame qui m'a demandé de passer
l'aspirateur à cause de la sallaz - rob
alors ça suffit comme ça vous amuse
étape y aller
bayou matin m'enfin faut
lorgues où juteux rives
j'ai oublié mes clés actuellement
naturellement n'a pas encore fermé
l'époque ça empeste mes choux fleurs
dans toute la rue au milieu du salon
tu veux dire mais qu'est ce que tu
appelles rentrée avant quatre ou sept
modes distincts paparazzi dû patienter
pendant des heures mon chapeau était pas
prévu c'est elle est terrible c'est ça à
chaque fois jean louis gély pourquoi
m'as-tu attendu toi parce que tu croyais
que j'allais laisser une nouvelle bonne
tout seul dans l'appartement
bon bah c'est vrai je ne pensais pas que
cet appel pas avant d'avoir vu mon
nouveau challenge
est ce que tu en penses un homme habillé
oui dit on perd on sera fou c'est le
côté velazquez qui m'a amusé tu permets
que des seuils n'ont pas fait attention
attention c'est par addition très
fragile mais faut-il vraiment très chaud
n'est ce pas il est ravissant un peu
jeune pour toi oui bah ma petite fille
j'ai compris ce chapeau est à moi et le
restera là mais c'est curieux maintenant
comme tu prend la mouche des comptes
rappelle que tu n'as fait vingt matches
est toujours debout mais est-ce que je
peux être en retard wima physique 13h10
d andy dont tu vois deux mignonnes de
déposer mon chapeau dans la penderie je
suis brisé chez incapable de faire alors
je les rentre pas trop tard un ne rentre
pas trop tard ne rentre pas d'elle
adele s'est fait discrètement adèle
adèle adel atteint
qu'est ce que c'est que ce déménagement
enfin en arrivant je me suis pris les
pieds dans le tuyau sauf miracle nous ne
soit pas passé les rames et avait
justement là j'étais juste en train
quand même assez large et arabes alors
ramassé tous appuyé que ça ne se
reproduise pas 1
voilà comme jeu comme je voyais pas
rentrer madame g j'ai mis le chou fleur
au gratin
je n'ai pas votre don de double vue je
l'avais de filet
monsieur antoine il aime le chou-fleur
grâce à elles n'ont juste pas le chou
fleur au gratin ça n'a aucune importance
avait après vous vous plaisez ici par
minuad elle répondent quand tout à fait
stylet mais j'ai attention vous prendre
en mal vous formez elle irait tout ça et
patronne c'est ça on va oublier le passé
et gardez pour vous ce genre de
remarques à bien madame le téléphone
madame est folle on madame on téléphone
il faut entendu la sonnerie enfin ça va
sonner madame
sasol
[Applaudissements]
aller raconter enfin répondu oui on
maintenant vous savez moi même pas
beaucoup sa télé fera pas hyper à
l'erreur
alors non non c'est peine et non plus
non c'est la nouvelle bonne ouïe ouïe
ccc qui s'est même chacha gassin canada
la chasse à fait rassurée quand c'est
comme ça maintenant
pendant le chant gaza non mais n'importe
quoi devant la cour tout quoi alors
mado à l'hommage au sephora chez mado
cher mado au coûteux nous étions nous
étions absolument de jeunes y est
absolument désolés pour ce déjeuner à
midi
mais vraiment je te pouvant tom non
c'est absolument épouvantable ça on met
alors à votre belle votre belle chambre
s'attaque à pitonner encore non
les gens à aller au mcdo alors qu'est ce
que vous allez faire
qu'est ce que vous allez faire vous
allez changer l'appartement dont vous
avez bien bref ça veut dire que vous
avez bien raison ça vous avez ainsi vous
a plu vous avez les moyens
quand je pense que quand je pense quand
je pense que lens pense que gaston ne
veut même pas faire repeindre la cuisine
oui ce toit se soit pas rien de
particulier non chez maxim mais c'est
une seconde badauds se massent aux
moines ado j'avais une halte était dite
dont le mal que vous me disiez ce soir
chez maxim
oui coûté pourra s'habiller a priori je
ne sais pas qu'on varie n'est pas là
mais je ne voit pas d'objection à
quelles heures à 7 heures
mais c'est entendu je serais ravi si ces
gens tu sais tu es bien gentil à vous
que ma tension mado et 10 étaient
entendus alors à ce soir enfin mme
adorent voir chez mado je m'occupe de ma
gueule en cas de succès à tel ou tel à
telle heure à telle à telle ou telle
personne ne donnera là ce soir nous
sommes tous invités bovine et monsieur
antoine aussi a évidemment quelle
question fait qu'est-ce que je vais
faire du chou-fleur parce que vous
voudrez vous demanderez à den adel
je vais vous demander à dell pour le
téléphone là comment avez vous deviné
enfin je veux dire c'est comme ce matin
je sais pas je sais pas tu es la
première fois lumières vont pas attacher
d'importance mais enfin ça vous arrive
souvent toute la journée madame hausse
est curieux c'est tout à fait curieux
madame n'est pas fasciste union matin
non je suis pas fâché bien sûr pourquoi
serais-je pas chez simplement si je
gardais mon service je veux savoir à
quoi m'en tenir
bien sûr et ainsi vous prétendez tout
deviner ce que pensent les gens
prévoir l'avenir chez daiwa
c'est pourtant vrai madame ça a commencé
j'étais toute petite nuit alors d'abord
des petites choses sans importance
n'allez lorgnons pp qu'il avait garée
une lettre qui devait arriver si c'était
un garçon ou une fille comme amer
attendent un bébé c'est passionnant jeu
je me souviens d'une fois je joue à la
marelle avec des petites copines quand
tout d'un coup j'ai comme une
illumination
qu'est ce que je vois ma tante adèle ma
tante
oui adel comme moi s'appelait louis
gasset et qui est et qui avait disparu
depuis trois ans que tout le monde
croyait fort elle était dans un salon
mue avec des beaux messieurs plein de
lumières et même qu'elle était assise
sur les genoux d'un militaire
[Rires]
alors je vais 4 à 4 annoncé la bonne
nouvelle à maman et jansone de ses pairs
de tarn
allez savoir pourquoi l'equal pay a dit
dos adel vous êtes dur une pas vous
vantez madame n'a qu'à poser des
questions vous êtes question que ces
questions seraient pas là parce que vous
dites là comme ça je suis pas que c'est
trop bête question d'un coup c'est trop
beau tir dans l'étape kaka la dame là
qui vient de téléphoner madame gages à
ça que fait-elle en ce moment là
attendez attendez
madame gaschard oui oui oui attendez
attendez il faut que je me chauffe bon
alors là voilà la voilà vous la voyez là
voilà elle a des bigoudis oui elle
casser un oeuf dans un bol ouais un
autre we ll verts du lait avait fait un
entremets cachaça faisant l'autre mais
ça m'étonnerait
qu'est ce que veut elle se prépare pour
ce soir je veux voir lors d'une ruine à
côté d'elle madame est contente de moi
c'est normal c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
absolument convaincu prenons quelqu'un
d' attention parce que cette fois je
pourrais contrôler prenons mademoiselle
solange par exemple que fait-elle en ce
moment mademoiselle solent oui en
attendant la voilà lé cours dans la rue
oui et aux balles en un beau chapeau
avec de grandes poches
à chaque pas est plus une jaune ne
quittez pas
j'en ai déçu j'avais appliqué mon
chapeau à l'appliquer monchatre on m'a
piqué mon chapeau je peux rien à voir un
mois dans cette maison mais le perd rien
pour attendre
je lui dis va te voler mon chapeau mais
elle m'a piqué mon jeu vous commencez à
devenir très très apprécié avec
continuer ou non mais c'est que moi je
voudrais pas faire d'histoires lancé me
nommer nommer que ceux ci
c'est un jeu où ça c'est un jeu vous
savez du simple
vous savez ce qui m'amuserait maintenant
c'est de savoir ce que fait monsieur
monsieur et où il est actuellement
ça ça oui monsieur allez je vous écoute
il frappe à une porte
ouais il entre oui c'est une chambre à
coucher
là il ya une dame en chemise de nuit
quand une mère d'un continent et adle
continuez à un âge où leur donne mais si
je je crois qu'ils s'embrassent madame b
ils s'embrassent
ils sont proches auxquels heureux au bo
que l'heureux après vingt cinq ans le
mariage où les infractions mais non mais
sa réponse j'ai vu vous trompez 1 alors
n'essayez pas de vous rattraper les
seules épaules votre nom qui prenait ça
comme un jeu non n'essayez pas de vous
rattraper au soft vous a peut-être
confondu peut-être que c'était monsieur
en toile je suis sûr que c'était pas mal
il semble avoir compris que c'était pas
monsieur antoine va comme ça bon alors
mais continuons à chevron le tableau de
famille que futile monsieur antoine non
je suis en toi tu siffles il et il est
en train aux basses à la définit
d'ailleurs comme ça c'est agaçant soir
la savoie je me suis en douanier il ne
dessine
vous m'avez fait peur des cinémas
villers bien et me bourdon
oui match et c'était joli qu'est ce que
ça peut donner sur des sols mais je ne
sais pas une locomotive
[Rires]
au niveau mondial mon cher petit temps
tu animes consolera tous et vilaine est
lui assez le contraire de son père
travailleur pas que vous êtes folle de
retard 6 2 la fatigue n'est pas la
cuisine si j'y suis ben rien à blaye
toujours selon turc a fait elle
m'accueille au divorce elle brise mon
foyer en foyer
allez on dit cette moyenne
c'est super super u et bien maman encore
des drames aussi toi mon antoine hausse
et le dernier mois alors voyons c'est
pas sérieux toit en toit nous lie
ta maman est une femme d'affaires je
suis décidé à demander le divorce quoi
c'est bien pour les enfants c'est dur
mais vous êtes grands maintenant vous
êtes accro à tu sais j'ai j'ai résisté
aussi longtemps que j'ai pu mais je peux
pas aller au delà de mes fort bon papa
ou est il si sa peau papa tu mourir de
rire j'en ai l'est olala les odeurs
lentilles ne faut pas s'y fier à ses
quelque chose je comprends maintenant
pourquoi il réclame et des soirées
tranquilles en famille sa partie de
bridge ils se fatiguent et l'après midi
de cette info c'est impossible mais
puisque je te dis que je les ai vu de
mes yeux vu où justement comment au seul
essai de vue je te dis je les ai vus
j'ai vu j'ai vu enfin mois après je
refusais je répugne à te donner des
détails sordides
moi non non non vraiment je peux pas y
croire parce que tu es comme moi tu
comme moi antoine tu ne vois le mal
nulle part as tu sais mon chéri ta maman
n'aura pas une vie heureuse
faut que tu sois très gentille et bien
sûr ma mort
si encore j'avais été dont sa console de
beaucoup de choses mais je suis contente
de les avoir données merci maman mon
petit garçon mon cher petit garçon oui
tu as bien travaillé cet après midi oui
mais ville et bien ça c'est bien tu as
été at-on cours et ben naturellement oui
c'est bien ça c'est bien
la locomotive à l'avancement ça t'étonne
que je te demande ça mais je sais tout
mon chien je sais tout petit antoine qui
ne la montrera quand elle sera terminée
la locomotive
oui je te prends mais maintenant je te
le promets à la papa voilà donc bon soir
laissant frau laquelle journée moi je
n'en peux plus oh quelle bonne odeur ça
donne faim 24 ans
alors qu'est-ce que vous moi raconte
écoulée le coût est de nouveau antoine
antoine je signale que dès demain matin
j'irai voir m chapotot pour prendre des
dispositions qu'il te fera savoir depuis
jeudi
au cas où cela intéresserait que je suis
décidé à demander le divorce
voilà tu as trouvé l'homme de ta vie
mais bravo coup de papattes en supplie
maman est en train de se monter la tête
dépêche-toi tirer les choses au clair il
faut de plus le savoir pour ceux dont on
accuse d'un mot je vais le confondre où
étais-tu cet après midi un nouveau tout
l'après midi
tu dois quitter ton bureau que pour
venir directement ici non en effet non
en effet donc pour eux de savoir qui
était cette dame en chemise qui te
recevait dans sa chambre et que tu en as
he nous allons charger
en tant qu est ce que ça veut dire des
familles de la situation nous laisse pas
reprendre sa respiration un une annonce
c'était ma soeur geneviève avait été
brouillée depuis 15 ans pour une
ridicule histoire de trésorerie mais je
ne viens vitalité avec une branche et il
m'a semblé tout naturel d'aller faire
une petite visite écoute c'est papa
alors maman qu'est ce que tu attends
pour te jeter aux courbes a pâli
demandait pardon hein
tu vois ce que tu dis ne décroche le
téléphone mois téléphone le ciel ça mais
ça va tu te sentais pas inventa soeur
depuis se poser une question d'enjeu
au moins là on peut tout parce que je
n'ai vraiment rien à cacher comment sais
tu que tu allais chez geneviève adèle
sera-t-elle elle t'a vu mais comme ce
matin et gâcha salle qui dormait pendant
c'est un danger public cette fille là
comment tu peux dire tu m'en donnes des
émotions tout moment là sylvie post
fusion pour une histoire pareille des
dents à petit tu m'a fait plaisir de la
flanquer à la porte un visionnaire des
chalets formidable aux bruins d'histoire
qui compte maintenant il l'a gardée à
mon service en question dit non à prades
est ce que tu vas toujours chez m
chapotot demain matin on ne crie pas une
montre à ce poids pour que je t'ai me
dégoûte des anglais geneviève st trop
contents même passé à brancher à la
salle des médias de parler tout en m et
2,10 donc on était plus tranquille avec
regina s'est pas alors ma grosse c'est
pour bientôt
je félicite adèle vous pouvez être fiers
de vous oui mais vous rattraper avec ma
mère m'a jarretière salle l'a peut-être
mais elle est morte s'est passé hier
c'était l'effet mois encore pour
révolutionner la maison avec tous vos
aliments à madame était sur le point de
demander de tout simplement
mais moi je voulais rien qui va tirer
les vers du nez d'apprendre à vous taire
au va très bien et très bien c'est comme
ça qu'on me remercier merci mais non
mais de quoi on va vous êtes en janvier
quand on me dit on may 6 1
ça vous seriez - si j'avais pas fais
coup la locomotive à madame parce que la
locomotive c'est vous oui c'est moi je
dis ce qui me passait par la tête
non parce que c'est pas des choses à
montrer une jeune fille et bien tant pis
vous n'aviez qu'à pas regardé à ce
moment là enfin ça c'est très chic
à vous d'avoir fait ce mensonge pour moi
merci at elle tout de même avec une dame
qui habite deux étages
tout ça vos parents ça je n'aurais
jamais cru ça do et bien alors je suis
fait comme les autres et vous vous
n'avez pas d'amoureux un non monsieur
antoine à mignonne comme vous êtes ça
n'aurait rien d'étonnant
bhattarai pardon je ne savais pas que
vous étiez vestale vestale du tout
allait continuer oui bah moi je perds
temps de penser à toutes ces bêtises moi
pour moi l'amour ce sacré mais je ne
veux pas de l'amour physique
voilà pour moi c'est ça se passera comme
au cinéma comme dans les romans de la
collection celle là pour moi j'attends
le prince charmant ne mais l'inconnu on
verra la vie en rose ça sera comme dans
les rêves bleus et leur après semble que
j'ai déjà entendu ça quelque part oui
mais vous n'êtes pas un sentimental est
pas moins chuté stial un euro dans le
bric
il faut de la chair fraîche abel je te
veux
salut toi tu fait la cour au boniche
maintenant si ça continue il va falloir
qu'on aille s'installer dans la cuisine
pour laisser le salon à mademoiselle
alors décolle pas de toute façon il sera
bien obligé d'y retourner à la cuisine
maman la renvoie et ben tu lui
demanderas serait trop long à expliquer
toujours aussi grâce aux boîtes bien on
n'a pas téléphoné pour moi naturellement
mamans mamies en retard et j'ai raté mon
rendez vous tu veux dire qu'on t'a posé
un lapin comme d'habitude ni mon pauvre
garçon pays je me demande vraiment ce
que tu es le plus bête lake ou comme va
soigner ton fois vieille fille fils à
papa a dit oui soeur doit y aller de
surprises parties aux divinités
caricature
[Applaudissements]
c'est assez enfin c'est une wii voilà
des histoires des vrais chiffonniers
sont liés mieux de vous habiller de vous
préparer pour le dîner pour le dîner où
j'avais complètement oublié de vous dire
que mal aux cages à sa téléphone et
qu'elle nous invite tous à dîner ce soir
chez maxi voilà des bassins pas question
j'ai accepté
oui tu n'as qu'à téléphoner pour
décommander gaston qui m'agace aurait pu
dire plutôt là et toutes les idées ça
m'est complètement sorti la tête
j'adore maxime et c'est maintenant le
seul endroit qui soit très chic
dommage que je ne puisse pas y aller
j'adore vos téléphones très rapport à
moi non plus tôt possible et je peux pas
laisser tomber leur caisse vous ne ferez
pas cet accord il s'engage à sa
dépouille et vous enfin que dia ce dîner
est extrêmement important pour votre
père en soi par exemple mais je le ferai
rien à voir avec ce monsieur et je ne
veux pas avoir à fermer d'humanoïdes
mais je suis déjà plus qu'à moitié
engager ces choses là se font très vite
et gachassin attend ma réponse la vache
r tu t'es passé mois jusqu'à présent tu
continueras l' instant même à câbles
basse et c'est certain je me suis laissé
un petit but d'entraîner m'écoute chérie
tu es un homme d'affaires tu pourras lui
parlez pas dans ce genre d'affaires
doit-on gachassin ne m'inspire aucune
confiance bien tu refuses de
m'accompagner non seulement je refuse
mais je t'interdis d'aller à ce titre
des miens je me débrouillerai tout seul
comment va passer mc cinéma convoque à
10h15 par l'état puisque votre père me
fait défaut c'est très très peur voilà
c'est égal à cette régate us et gaston
web os meus laissé seul en face de ce
renard évidemment une fois que tu loire
a confié tous tes papiers il peut
disparaître
on n'aura aucun retour me suivre est à
lire dans le temps c'est ce que tu dis
mon chéri oui bon ça c'est très embêtant
mais comment savoir ce que ce diable
d'homme a dans la tête
eh bien rien de plus simple en nomade
elle
la poche et maxime bonjour à tous quand
un clin d'oeil à dévoiler ses intentions
cachées de gachassin et on sait à quoi
s'en tenir
voilà ce que j'appelle antoine parler
pour ne rien dire je n'en suis pas si
sûr je n'en suis pas si sûr
je n'en suis pas si sûr ces tags a
priori l'idée semble difficilement
acceptable et pourtant équipée est nette
mais tu divagues adel n'a prouvé que les
états faillible et à moisdon même
famille celle ci vous fait marcher elle
avait que ça a pris ce matin alors les
sept seront intéressantes c'est tout
dans un propos mon petit poussin mon
chapeau il ya des succès cet après midi
pourquoi pas watcha pouvait alors tu
vois un conseil tu restes dans ton quoi
et tu te fais le plus petit possible
je vais m'occuper d'expédition au
téléphone à manama doha chasse a en lui
disant qu'une amie de solaris aux
lenteurs quant à maman parle
est ce que tu veux te taire et intérêts
je sais d'aucune amics langer de passage
et que nous non non tu as vu comment
elle et fagotée haddad est un bon ne
crie pas comme ça te fait sursauter mais
tout ça s'arrangera très bien du prêtre
est nommé robe du soir
maquillée coiffée je suis sûr qu'elle
passe très bien ça se voit pas mais elle
est très jolie
un prix de beauté petit suffit que la
pauvre fille ouvre la bouche pour que
des gages à s'asseoir immédiatement
compte à qu'ils ont à faire mon petit
plus sympa les gars chasse à se rendre
compte de quoi grands dieux ils ont
commun comme du pain d'orge abel leur a
même pas besoin de parler ça tu trouve à
l'avant ça me dira que le strict
nécessaire
voilà non mais vous l'avez vu à table
vous l'avez vu à sage rire et tiens si
on servait des écrevisses pas du tout tu
verras pas du tout parce que je
choisirais pour elle furet compote du
ragga tour est joué
quoi la seule fois de sa vie qu'elle ira
chez maxime c'est vraiment pas de chance
en traction quelques faux et le cadre
des toilettes publiques dans mes enfants
c'est pas une partie de plaisir
alors alors puis d'objection bon de
toute façon tu as décidé à l'emmener
oui je suis décidé à langue et tout est
décidé à m'accompagner oui je suis
décidé de le 2 serait ce que pour
essayer de limiter les dégâts
sa femme était trop faible écoute s'est
déclenché alors je l'aï enfin à faire
gaffe sur gaffe
nous allons être couvert de ridicule
publiquement et quant à toi maman tout
l'héritage tu n'en verra jamais la moule
sort jamais moi cette façon de mauvaise
augure si tu t'arranges très bien comme
j'en suis persuadé tu sera pas la
dernière en profite pour deux à del je
vous parlais oui madame me demande pour
me donner congé vous parle de sommes
surtout pas monsieur un petit peu
emballé tout à l'heure mais tout ceci
est oublié tout ceci est oublié mais
alors que madame ne me demande plus de
lui donner deux consultats si retoque ça
c'est un coup dur et demain voilà qui
coupe court à tes projets insensés
c'est drôle tu ne me connais pas quand
j'ai une idée dans la tête tu sais pas
pour le moment que j'ai encore mon
service et c'est moi qui comment on va
gérer le plat non syndicats
moi qui voulais vous faire une surprise
est ce que c'est la surprise eh bien
nous sommes tous invités ce soir en
joyeuse bande au restaurant et nous vous
emmenons avec nous c'est pas si adel un
restaurant que vous n'en avez jamais vu
plein de lumière de dorures de miroir
avec un orthez on vous rappellera
longtemps de votre vie oui pourquoi
éperdument toute la nuit
un mot sur toile et ses danseuses comme
un dieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est effrayant
oh
deux émigrés et bien pas moi et aucune
envie d'aller me coucher semble pourtant
que quatre heures passées c'est une
heureuse adore tout naturellement pour
une fois qu'on va dans une boîte de nuit
que tu peut être pas tout cela juste
hommage au dieu qu'il est ennuyeux
tu avais d'assaut temps moi j'en ai le
feu aux joues moi aussi de mon camp je
pense à cette soirée ont beaucoup de thé
follement ok je le nom est une
inconscience pour moi plus je suis bien
content que ce soit terminé
je suis aussi mauvaise humeur que titien
est situé à les payer l'addition
tu sembles oublier ma chère aidé mais
que cette étrange il n'était pas
précisément une partie de plaisir mais
il de tête famille qui pouvaient qui a
bien failli mal tourner faille et je te
prouve optimisme a pas ça pouvait pas
être pire on vous faisait deux bourgeois
deux offres petit vaugeois
il y avait une partie super bass est
allé gagner grâce à moi tu pars un peu
vite c'est pas encore fait adèle ajusté
aussi de les écouter un traître mot je
l'observais médias pas encore de quoi
crier victoire à biak adèle va nous dire
les intentions cachées de gachassin
qu'est ce qu'elle attend tu vas me dire
qu'est ce qu'elle attend puisqu'elle
attend que l'atom sur ton de la voiture
des caches ashton devrait voulu qu'elle
pas te voir deux feux n'a pas de jugeote
par moments terribles mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fait tout et qu'elle nous qu
elle me suivait avec moi parce qu'elle
regagne pas directement son sixième pour
que les deux oublié demain matin tu vas
te ment pas
mais comme on le laisse tout de même à
l'ascenseur le temps de descendre et
remonter de ma vie je ne remettrai les
pieds dans tous les endroits où
s'installer ce soir qu'ils entendent de
ma vie enfin mais qu'est ce qu'elle a
mais pourquoi c'était très réussi notre
table n'est pas passée inaperçue voilà
et alors
alors sache je me sens assez sûr de moi
pour soutenir les regards ne serait pas
moi c'est mon chapeau
et son esclave dans la boîte de nuit ce
don chapeau que très long mais passée
une certaine heure tout est permis
vous ne le savez pas les shows jeu
levrat encore que la partie la
cartomancienne de l'endroit où elle a
suivi de table en table en la traitant
de tous les noms paul avait bien les
gens se retrouvent ça tue tout le monde
pouvait dire la bonne aventure et son
exhibition de danse au milieu de la
piste des lettres de leur espèce ne
l'est plus excentricité 2 milliards
d'eur c'est tout ça beaucoup
impressionné les gachassin lui surtout
apparemment tout il avait tué trois de
champagne j'espère que sa femme ne l'a
pas entendu promettre à adele de
divorcer pour l'épouser j'espère il
répliquait spatiaux est-ce que j'ai plus
rire qu'autre et quand tu mets quand on
sent que ce que les hommes étaient
derrière ça prouve leur goût qui eût cru
en la voyant débarquer si ce matin
qu'elle serait devenue le soir même une
des reines du paris nocturne
je suis une fée un nouveau pygmalion
c'est pas sorcier avec terrain comme
quoi tu vois ma chérie ces gars c'est
bien l'habit qui fait le moine à la
relativité des choses
vanitas vanitatum bouge très bien les
putschs et d'avoir cette affaire où
calais voilà certains cantons faisant
d'eux des militants faisaient de
s'amuser avec l'ascenseur
résultat on est resté coincé entre deux
étages il a fallu faire un dossier
gymnastique pour sortir mon bon vin se
valent tous mais moins bon que je fasse
ma vaisselle la gestuelle
nous avons dîné deux oui non mais celle
de midi il y en avait si peu ça valait
pas la peine que je me mette fin
justement elle peut encore attendre
propos bousquet longe avaler et la
lessive il faut vous pour vous que je
demande à madame de nous rappeler demain
que elle me rappelle que lala rappel de
rats paulo donc j'appelle à des défis
pour hachette usa lui manquerait je vais
en profiter pour faire la cuisine à fond
m'enfin cursus ne pensez pas on n'y
pensait pas surfer ya planeur n'y a pas
d'art pour sa voile me sens train est
conscient très basses en remontant la
manche ce qui tend est-ce que vous allez
me laissait pas le rater c'est bien
d'avoir du coeur à l'ouvragé d'être
vaillante comme ça mais chaque chose en
son temps
demain tout ce que vous voudrez ce soit
asseyons nous et qu'on sent tranquille
murray nommé demain j'aurai pu enlever
ça le fait rire
alors alors alors un peu de repassage
vous a fait bon vivre
bioware quand je met le linge à tromper
ce qui lui prend tout acquis et
l'arrière puis l'après-midi à 14 matches
un peu plus le tenir de près puisque je
vous dis qu'il faut que je fasse quelque
chose puisque et vous dis je voudrais
aller dans le détail nervosité dans ce
sont les trans divinatoires c'est très
compliqué messieurs nous veiller jusqu'à
demain matin nous sommes demain matin je
ne la lâcherai pas qu'est ce que tu as
fais mon petit tu vas les médias tu m'en
faire un petit peu de tessala cannor
c'est un faux messi dans un site à
pleine charge
andré volontiers je suis la bonne la
bosse maintenant mais alors à del
adele a des souhaits du raisonnable dès
lors qu'un seul à être raisonnables ce
soir ferait profiter jusqu'au bout
alors alors qu'on tente de votre petite
soirée
pendant nom mia et ben vous est
difficile peut-on savoir pourquoi tu
n'as pas fait danser c'est pourquoi que
je ne suis pas assez bien pour lui la
part d'une bonne ça n'a pas servi à
grand chose
apriso la masse dit
de la politique intense elle a très
mauvais esprits c'est une roja ça il
vous suffisait pas et maintenant qu
était furieux pensiez pas trop lui vous
étiez jouer ajoute c'était dégoûtant
henson toi maintenant la pauvre fille
était dans service commandé
et quand il vous embrasse et dans le cou
aux dites pas le contraire je vous ai vu
comme ça vous savez votre vie privée ne
me regarde absolument pas souvent pieds
monsieur cachaça je m'en contre fiche
sachez seulement qu'on n'est pas du
rosaire d'enfants mari me trompe
personne
notez bien
qu'est ce qui te papa tu deviens fou
quoi mais tu deviens complètement
qu'est ce qui te prends tu es là tu
marques tu pas que sa manette recoucher
tiens ouais bah quand vous avez des
parts est débarrassé plancher d'heure
sur le divan dont monsieur vrais pauvres
13,2 rüder sur le disant allez allez à
là tout le monde est un peu énervés
fatigués tout ça va passer à ses rivaux
c'est à dire écoutez pas écouté ma
tranquillement adèle voulez vous voilà
ce soir au cours du dîner est ce pas
nous avons parlé enfin vous m'avez
entendu parler à faire avec monsieur
gachassin bon de cet entretien monsieur
gachassin avait-il une arrière-pensée
pas les chiffres avancés correspondent
et il à la réalité
enfin bref dois-je accepter ce qui me
propose
ouais ouais
vous avez raison ne répondait pas tout
de suite ne répondait pas du tout
réfléchi si c'est très important car
d'un mot d'un mot vous pouvez nous
ruiner ou faire notre fortune est la
vôtre en même temps et au héros déjà
gérant rien ceci est une affaire
sérieuse il me sembla nous vous écoutons
- des disques on est méchant avec moi ni
rien tu vois tu vois toi toi tu l'a vexé
tu avais bien besoin d'eux mais
rétrograde cette utopie n'est pas cet
art comme ça elle boude mais non aboud
banlieue sûr que nous que vous n'êtes
pas aller at-elle faut pas être
susceptible s'est pas montrée montre à
monsieur antoine que vous n'êtes plus
intelligente que lui ne me fait comme
s'ils n'existaient même pas non mais ça
ne te dirai rien
je la tuerais
je crois maintenant il est largement
temps mais qu'il a levé la séance
en fait ils devaient sentir concerné
quand même pas aussi une [ __ ] fabius de
ma chance moi je manque de sens avec le
souffre de brûlures d'estomac
je suis excédé par toute cette histoire
c'est que vous entendez vous empêcher
monsieur d'aller d'aller louis malades
comme il est c'est pas gentil ce n'est
vraiment pas vous avez un papa vous
qu'est ce que vous diriez si on agissait
ainsi avec votre papa votre pauvre vieux
par henri pons le savent quand il agacé
avis ma maison et que voit on était bien
content parce qu'il était toujours sous
et nouveautés comme père alors
hier que des belges à vraiment faire du
sens du bord une dernière fois l'alerté
donnée les petits renseignements que
nous vous demandons en échange de cette
soirée inoubliable nord vous comme pour
nous c'était décidé rappelé alors je
parlerai oui je parlerai si monsieur
antoine me fait des risques s'il ne
s'agit que de cela
enfin vraiment à del en toile j'ai tenté
ma les excuses à la bonne j'ai pas
d'excusés à faire et je retiens rien de
ce que j'ai dit on entre temps je te
plaît que l'on sorte une fois pour toute
à sa dignité
faut pas croire antoine écoute moi
antoine si tu fais des excuses à des
tempêtes offrira ce chronomètre en or
dont tu as tellement tort c'est vrai
papa comme toi j'espère que tu au dessus
de ça voudrait bien masquer anomalies
tandis que je n'étais que tu n'auras
puisque jalu n'est qu'il aurait il le
rate une amende a marché conclut qu au
sahel voix j'en étais sûre et voir
l'inde doit régner
6,5 alors en toile ses excuses ça vient
ça les roms addex tout cela toutes mes
excuses qu'elle va me faire sortir de
mes jours je recommence adèle petits
coeurs noble et fier je dépose à vos
pieds en toute humilité une gerbe des
excuses vous êtes une adorable poupée la
plus jolie des soubrettes la reine des
emmerdeuses que tu peux m'énerver que je
m'énerve mais bon je suis veuf était
premier en tant que toi
bush
habitué
hélas comme ça ne serait pas ne me
tairais pas maçon il ferait pas bon de
singles et moi la paix la police la
police de san et sa bourgeoise à
kapitalis guidon pour le grand soir on
est bon un jeu des plus tôt pour
regarder pas comme ça si la détente
nerveuse alors cinq minutes tout le
monde est au lit mettez là allongé dans
la santé tu peux être maladroit dire est
opaque il a été bon gardien
[Rires]
pourquoi on aime n'est pas méchante du
défaut sera capable de tuer rien pour
nous embêter ivre comme elle est mais
vous mentez pas la tête je vous assure
qu'on ne vous veux que tu bien vous êtes
gène braf
poutine des simagrées mettre les
sessions séchez vos larmes séchées
séchez vos lèvres rêve un mouchoir
la fois contente ça va mieux ça va mieux
oui c'est sûrement la mienne j'avais pas
vu vous aviez deux yeux noisette oui tu
que les blues genia des miens lisons
noisette avec homme de poigne en effet
l'on paie et des ouïes al adel a regardé
chez nous et on peut dire une chose
elle fond comme neige au soleil et ont
vu quand on se laisse faire oui
plus on gagne plus on a envie de
regarder c'est plein de choses qui
bougent comme dans l'aquarium de reims
elle je louche toxicomanes écoute maman
je vais tout de même avec une machine
encore
oh je fais ou le déforme appel
plongeons dans les profondeurs sous
marines brad wall la chaleur moi parce
que je suis bien
tu sais gagne plus en plus gros tu sors
ma chérie sa chienne adorée jcta l'avait
complètement de bligg màj suite à quand
ma grosse toujours rien de temps mais je
te tromper on veut c'est papa c'est quoi
la harmoye ce soit une grossesse
nerveuse
bastien qui genre je ne vois pas d'autre
explication qu'est-ce que tu en france
montré sommes effectivement une
grossesse nerveuse et une explication
merci pas pour moi tu m'as donné adel un
peu de thé d'été oui les gens du peuple
confonds toujours le thé la tisza aller
buvait ça ça nous fera des maisons pas
vraiment jamais alors buffet c'est
benoît samson et dites nous ce que nous
attendons de vous depuis ce débat dans
[Rires]
le champagne non non non non non non non
non non non non tu vois ma patience a
des limites
alors adèle je vous offre talent je vous
ordonne les normes et n'amène pas malade
ou tourner non tout de suite haut la
main eh ben j'ai voulu à diront la
vérité je vous le dirai vous êtes un
imposteur
voilà ce que vous la poste à la faveur
de coïncidences successives vous avez pu
nous faire illusion et tout ça dans le
but de nous exploiter mais pas longtemps
ma chère peu mais pas longtemps et le 27
rue de l'arcade
qu'est ce qui se passe sur 27 de la rue
des arcades et bien demandé à madame
c'est une adresse qu'elle connaît bien
du dôme au toit oui regardez moi et 11
et dire qu'il n'y avait pas deux fois
par semaine en cachette de monsieur
owens être d'arc à nouveau maman
et demain c'est fait de mes jeux de
somme de t'expliquer tu me somme qui me
some tu veux comme tu m'as ça après tout
pourquoi n'aurais-je pas le droit
comme toutes les autres femmes d'aller
quand bon me semble
dans un institut de beauté c'était drôle
ça mais je comprends ta tante et
continuelle besoin d'argent mais
beaucoup de chair pas fraîcheur mais
c'est toi qui en trois sets avec les
autres jeux tu n'as rien à dire mais en
même temps tout d'abord aller ils
trichent tous les soirs ont pris c'est
une fabuleuse en fait on pas ta soeur
s'explique oui la coupe de bridge
rapporté à la finale de la bourboule aux
riverains
je ne triche jamais sauf quand je suis
en famille mais c'est exactement la même
source vraiment gaston alors là tu me
déçois horriblement maîtrise chez toi un
escroc qu'alors
je suis devant mais j'aime gagner puis
j'ai tourné au dieu après vous pouvez
quoi mais les courts de cléry culture on
n'y allait pas souvent on vous préférez
des promenades en voiture avec les
américaines d'émeutes et nous on sait
bien ce john je ne sais quoi
non tu m'as parlé un jour dont il s'agit
est maintenant c'est pisser binky ses
saveurs un garçon très bien
il est à l'ambassade il me promène de
temps en temps dans sa voiture tu sais
antoine l'impérial dernier modèle sera
la grosse et les nord nous nous aimons
et de toute façon s'il ne s'est pas
encore déclaré s'attendre à face je veux
bien bien né le bilan question c'est pas
du tout mais pas du tout ce que vous
croyez
la grosse voiture américaine par dit
c'est pas difficile seul sauveur
l'ambassade
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai un bon paquet pour tout le monde
alors mardi comment écouter sur toile
alors
on va regarder un peu pour demain matin
tôt je crois que le marchand les animaux
ont tous de boucher de bay je n'ose y
croire ça lance mon trésor j'aurais de
moi te dire at-elle haut doubs
merci et puisque vous lisez si bien dans
l'avenir vous devez savoir que vous
l'emporterez paradis nietzsche hop nous
voilà ça d'où l'aide
vous avez encore c'est du joli
au temps pour vous j'ai rien dit et
pourtant important à oui elle vous plaît
bien à la dame du second étage un club
ça allait plutôt sexy non web apps en ce
moment si vous la voyez avec sa crème
antirides
la bella 75 ans beaucoup moins avec la
fonte d'été roulait pas à les charger
votre ton tête on en joue et antiquaires
cette folle mais qu'on ne se couchait il
est temps non mais ça vaut plus le coup
mais pourquoi il veut que je leur fasse
leur petit déjeuner à 7h30 du matin
cette bande de cinglés ou par non non
vous excusez pas je pense exactement
comme vous croyez qu'ils dorment
ah bah ça vous devriez le savoir mieux
que moi vous tu veux mais jamais deviné
s'ils dorment
pourvu qu'on les dérange pas comment ça
c'est bien on dans ce sens par dix ans
dans son nom mais de quoi parlez vous
vous avez le diable au corps dansant
mais l'électrophone fait trop de bruit
temps mais enfin on peut danser samedi
l'as on peut danser bouger plate qu'on
essaye on va très doucement avec eux
tout à l'heure vous étiez jaloux de
gachassin
jamais de la vie d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
je me demande pourquoi je vous demande à
oui il est amoureux voit son blog vous
le savez pas mais moi je sais pour
genève
à oui encore une de vos visions non à
des émissions savez pas ce qui va
arriver maintenant
et bien pour une fois c'est moi qui vais
vous le dire
[Applaudissements]
bonjour ma chérie non mais des fois
je vous demande pardon mais c'est vrai
que c'était madame n'est pas un
compliment madone oui alors alors quoi
gachassin à manta ray du à salon de deux
et de trois un escroc je savais alors si
vous savez pourquoi me le demande je
m'en doutais pas un mot de cette petite
conversation à madame maria même cédé 7
vous faire parler
oudin a besoin en gamme entoure tenez
vous êtes une brave fille moche et
j'aimerais tout de même bien savoir ce
que j'ai fait moi route du chat ça par
exemple tabio non mais ma chérie ça va
signer ce trop vous demander à d'elle
que de me rendre mon déshabiller bon moi
je vous le tenez au chaud bon bah qu'est
ce qu'elle fait mais qu'est-ce que vous
êtes une map à vous déshabiller devant
tout le monde dans le salon mais face à
ces attaques depuis tenez garder le toit
tout de même bien merci madame pour me
va si bien
je crains que pour faire le ménage ne
soit pas tout à fait la tenue adéquate
puis fait de moi le plaisir d'aller
finir votre cigales dans la cuisine mais
ce pas yamada matus matis qu'est ce que
ça veut dire que je signe d'intelligence
en 3 vous glisser un billet dans la main
hall mais je te suis le mans mais non tu
l'as eu droit y est tu l'a questionné
sur des enfants sur ta femme mais encore
tu as acheté son silence
qu'est ce que tu vas encore imaginer
alors que tu at elle dit quelle horreur
de quelle infamie mattel encore couverte
pas pas la conscience tranquille il faut
croire la conscience tranquille mais je
savais qu'il savait ce qu'elle m'a dit
si tu le fais par les camps de quel
droit mais aucun poids dans une glace
pas besoin d'elle pour savoir ce qui se
cache derrière cette figure là tu sais
où tu vas tu sais on a la chance que
l'interdît tu es ici chez moi quand je
ne prends pas chercher ton le pen ne le
prends pas suspecte
lego tu dois maintenant vous vous battez
vos amis spectacle dans ta fille non non
vous n'êtes vraiment pas sérieux on peut
pas vous laisser seuls une minute à
peine réveillés tamer là qu'une idée en
tête aller à la cuisine de faire parler
la bonne je me doutais bien cadel y
était pour quelque chose mais il a
questionné derrière mon dos alors eu
triche
une triste long à bonnes habitudes mais
antoine gillet pas encore éveillés sud
faisant régner dans monsieur canapé dû
aller faire la grasse matinée
mais dans sa chambre elle est glacial
pauvre trésor va a dit qu'il soit
fatigué qu'est-ce que je devrais dire
comment le café tient battu temps qui
l'attend il qu'à appeler à des noms
qu'elle le fasse réchauffé mais voilà on
en profitera pour lui demander la
réponse telle réponse aux repas ils ont
tout oublié le dîner d'hier soir les cas
chassaing l'egypte encore aux cervelles
maso à peine la tête du club
inutile je vais interrogée à ce sujet
mme gaston c'est de ça dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure en phase comprend pas
alors pourquoi m'as-tu rien dit pourquoi
tous ces mystères la surprise est bien
les fêtes
elle est alors alors oui alors à la la
réponse est favorable mois sur les
thèmes personnels mais j'en étais sûr
sûr sûr j'en étais sûr qu est ce que tu
attends poêles et cheminées cachaça je
compte me rendre tout à l'heure ah bon
tiens tiens mes papiers
oui ils sont dehors de tout est
parfaitement tendance dans ma serviette
à pat a publié mais lamba non non ne n'y
mets héliopolis donnant pas no no no no
no no comme ça que ce taux excéder un
combien de maris serais heureux d'avoir
à se préoccuper de la fortune de leurs
femmes femmes riches
gaston il faudrait quelques valeurs et
deux terrains aux environs du coeur mais
sable et longe le nil
on trouve pas mieux placé
oui et cote à prouver mais tu t'emballes
truies sont pas encore vendus et coutal
est ce que tu es ce que tu vas oui ou
non
chez les gars chassèrent on parle on
parle là je voudrais prendre mon petit
déjeuner à mais n'a pas une minute à
perdre de gaston saute dans un taxi fils
et mon café au lait mais ça te couperait
l'appétit attend là je ne sortirai pas à
jeun moi cette somme donne des vertiges
je peux pas je te faire un petit
cendrier alors oui c'est vrai alors un
gros gros sabots chômage
non je mens grands mangent non je vais
aller moi même si les gars chasse à ces
deux beaucoup à faire et la bb et b j
bon appétit
pouf pouf on y voit des jeunes et pour
récompenser veut tout dire maman
ouais tu crois pas que je devrais aller
voir ce que ça donne oui vas voir c'est
faire d'elle mais ma petite fille tu
conseilles ne pas la brusquer
je tiens à ce qu'elle se place ici à l
aurait pas de chanter qui fait dans la
cuisine à longueur de jour
pourvu que ça dure crois-tu quelle
métamorphose
tu trouves pas c'est un peu rapide
extraordinaire si et comment
l'expliques-tu motus eu sept petites
bombes d'hier soir quelques coupes de
champagne ayant plus et bien moi j'ai ma
petite idée là-dessus laquelle mon
trésor demande en toi il sera te
préciser les choses en toi oui toi au
front parce que ton frère vient faire là
dedans à propos mon chéri tu n'avais pas
de cours ce matin jamais mardi
si tu me crois pas déranger la bonne non
non petite fille tu assez grands pour
savoir ce que tu as face à ces cas
reviennent petit à petit vous savez que
je vous préfère dans cette tenue un oui
ce ça dépend des goûts
à il faut que je prévienne la dame
qu'aujourd'hui je prends mon dimanche à
mais nous sommes mercredi
oui bah j'ai pas attendu la fin de la
semaine
j'allais vous le proposer allez vous le
propose faut que j'aille aux coiffes
ah oui et alors comme je suis de sortie
faut que je dise à madame que je ne
pourrais pas m'occuper du dîner parce
que moi conçue sort je rentre plus vous
rendra quand même qu un jour j'espère
que madame se rassure je ne suis pas une
nageuse
quoique on est proposé le double à
l'étagé en dessous pour moi ça c'est un
mensonge
ils ont une vieille cuisinière qui les
servent du puy-de-dôme sans doute est-ce
que tu peux nommer un seul salon de thé
s'ils atteignent le dit c'est que c'est
vrai et un point c'est tout
l'augmentation est accordé à des as bien
madame et alors il faudra engager
quelqu'un d'autre également parce que
moi je n'arrive pas tout seul mais
naturellement on les gros travaux nous
engagerons une femme de ménage
cela va soit à non pas une femme de
ménage non un valet de chambre simple de
rendement bon eh bien j'en parlerai avec
monsieur adel voilà un mois un bras
avec des cieux loiret yeux noirs a cessé
quand je me fais aux bonbons de
mademoiselle voir sur internet - je ne
peux rien vous port grands maîtres avec
madame fait ce qu'elle peut ça c'est oui
c'est avec ces petits détails là qu'on
s'attache à une maison mais bien sûr
j'espère au moins que vous ne vous
déplacez pas trop chez nous à sayad bon
et du moins bon
enfin si quelque chose ne va pas vous me
dites maintenant n'en fait tout de même
pas trop oui alors comme je suis de
sortie je laisse la vesa la mademoiselle
solange millet puis alors j'oubliais il
faudra mettre la radio dans la cuisine
parce que moi c'est que je compte
travailler en musique
d'accord d'accord tu vois ma chérie je
pense avoir les idées là mais je trouve
quand même que l' exagérer tippl tunes
passent s avec cette fille d'oxygen
audio triple idiote comprendront rien tu
ne comprends rien à taez la poule aux
oeufs d'or
grassin tu vas être doté est royalement
quand tu parles bien mon petit trésor
que tu réalises ce capital c'est plus
pour vous pour moi moi tu sais c'est dit
aux mamans ont serré qui va pouvoir d'un
pays des petites séances à la rue de
l'arcade et wav une devenu me de culte
païen du cabinet comme seule maman mais
je parle parfois fait pas par la cité
des falaises
amano gachassin pour la remercier pour
cette soirée d'hier soir c'était
vraiment formidable a été donné ce n'est
pas trop long je crois bien à mi-chemin
de l'appeler pas dire il y avait
longtemps que marie-chantal yeux et pas
après je me disais aussi
mais comment se fait-il que
marie-chantal pas encore appelée selon
doit s'ennuyer
sans sa petite marie chantal haton halo
madou mado enchères m'adosser de mai
nous étions absolument hier soir
ravi de cette de cette caisse qui amadou
vous avez une drôle de voix que se
passe-t-il
croix qu'est ce que vous dites
solange une chaise vide c'est vrai je
suis assez soit 6 à mon dieu mais c'est
pas possible
mais c'est pas possible alors mes mains
mais alors qu'est ce que nous allons
faire mais c'est horrible
matteau mon mari est parti pour ben avec
les papiers que vous savez la fête lui
singh par la fenêtre de ne pas monter
mado ma de coûter moins mado je compte
sur vous pour railler notre nom de votre
carnet d'adressés ecoutez-moi mado mado
allô allô mado mado mado mais maman tu
fais peur que se passe-t-il ces tirs et
ses terribles gachassin gachassin est
arrêté ils ont tout retourné chez lui on
l'a emmené rue des saussaies c'est
épouvantable nous allons être compromis
ou maman maman tu te rends compte de ce
que tu trouves cela c'est tout à fait
moi je suis suffisamment site allait
susciter comme ça dans la gueule du loup
mais on ne sait pas comment il va faire
quelques sourires il faut faire quelque
chose surtout pas s'affoler tout est
calme et aucune raison de s'affoler
y a vraiment aucune raison de s'affoler
s'est passé là par une valise le thermos
les couvertures lafuma faut que tu
ailles dommages au lycée de la foi avant
qu un garçon que vont-ils en faire
j'irai me jeter au pied du jus je lui
dirai je lui dirai ceci arrive alors à
vos lunettes
je vais demander à ses valeurs et donc
du jubilé tu prenais toujours de
l'argent comptant ton père a dû mal
comprendre distrait comme il n'y a pas
d'autre explication
mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait à terre à
terre y a plus moyen de tout temps
dérangé alors adapter très important il
faut que je parle il faut que ça mais
tais toi toi tais toi
adel etes-vous en état pour quoi faire
adèle c'est le moment ou jamais
d'exercer votre voyeurisme en bonbons
alors est-ce que vous avez question les
samoa les gentils toutous adèle je suis
complètement affolée oui dans quel état
je suis je c'est terrible mon mari
monsieur oui mais oui dit le monsieur en
ce moment là oui mon père oui son père
oui dit le voyez vous ben je ne voit que
lui tout ça est bien chez les gachassin
par jay leno show sas en effet venu chez
les chasseurs musique mais que fait-il
ben hibon aveyron qui amado gachassin le
musée un apéritif et gachassin lui tend
la boîte de cigares bon bah ils s'en
font pas vous jure alors ça y est oui je
peux m'en aller une minute at elle vous
êtes bien sûr de ce que vous voulez dire
ben oui quoi vraiment sûr et bien oui
quoi même m2 gachassin vient d'ouvrir la
radio zaz une samba
sajoo samba qu'est ce que je te disais l
avons tous un peu pourquoi nous dira
qu'il faut débourser votre crédulité
voit la famille sachez que gaza est en
prison en ce moment et qu'à cause de
vous ménard est montée quand même un peu
vocation mais pourquoi mais pourquoi lui
avoir dit que tout se passera même veine
gaza est en prison mimi alors y'a pas
moyen de dormir on sait que me antoine
antoine la police jan l'immeuble c'est
contre ton père tu dis je dis maman pour
ça fait les choses mais c'est à peu près
ça non mais sérieusement oui qu'est ce
que je viens de plaisanter oui ce défaut
en panne d'électricité dans l'air je
défends la parole à cette fuite des
forces en fait ces dons est revenue
regarde regarde la jouerie notre malheur
rigueur qu'est ce que je nomme je n'ose
y croit vous m'avez trahir mais laissez
moi vous êtes formidable on dit rien son
petit gaston
au delà du jeune thomas devinettes même
en bonne forme et a
elle allait me frapper vous allez chez
cerveau vous la laissez pas la lépi
tuner teuton plus c'est une étude ont
pas su cacher ce bassin
mais non mais non j'ai pas fait gaffe la
salle bon monsieur vous croyez que
l'aurait laissé partir comme ça sans
avoir pris son petit déjeuner il était
tranquillement installé à la cuisine on
passe à preixan mais alors pas mais tu
le sais rien gachassin est arrêté oui ça
on peut dire que qui l'a échappé belle
quand tu sais qu'à une minute prévention
et non pas pour vous j'ai jamais eu
l'intention de me rendre chez cet
aventurier encore moi lui remette la
fortune fait exactement 22 ans ma chérie
de mai que tu me mène par le bout du nez
ni vraiment shihri que tu es un mari
modèle
je suis toujours de ton avis n'a
remarqué mais ce que tu n'as pas
remarqué c'est que je n'en tiens
absolument aucun compte
tu racontes lagaf' pour avoir la paix je
me suis prêtée avec la complicité de la
dette à cette petite comédie
je pense à juste titre que tu nous en
tiendra pas trop rigueur allemande
tu nous as plus sûrs au real tim burton
oui mon aimée et ben pas moi at-elle
alors tout ce qu'on voulait raconter ce
matin à la celle et gachassin la radio
la samba c'était une invention pure
alors d'imaginer gachassin moisissant
sur la paille humide des cachots et 7
passes étaient malhonnêtes
non vraiment il n'y avait aucune mais
combien cette affaire va lui coûter 10
ans 15 ans les travaux forcés moi je
crois qu'ils sont sûrs a très bien
quelqu'un qui peut me le dire beaucoup
mieux que toi c'est adele alors à des
deux vous écoutons encore en face
maintenant ça comptait pas puis c'était
pour rire à en redire vous l'avez donc
je n'ai à nadine elle est apte à les
écouter mais qu'est ce que je veux je me
chambrent vous me sens toute chose mais
que ce que je m'asseyais suite des
opérations
j'espérais bien à fond le 6 mai les
nouvelles arrivées silence alors sinon
si vous perdez tous en même temps que
nous le pensons
c'est là ça va pas la ferme voit rien
enfin messi voyant un peu de patience
aux vins ils sont formidables et je
redis que jacques fois rien méditons ce
n'est vrai elle appelle dans son
assiette
giner attaqué ce qui vous arrive mais je
ne sais pas moi je ne sais pas
habituellement ça vient tout de suite
et puis là je ne sais pas je ne suis pas
très important je pousse je vous suis
encore là mais non non non la cie c'est
comme ça que c'est comme un grand trou
noir lui serait-il arrivé quelque chose
c'est bien peu sur ces phénomènes
psychologiques disparaissent aussi
mystérieuse banques qui sont voulus
finalement j'ai peine à y croire
abel comment vous sentez vous mais mieux
que jamais voulez vous vous allongez
imad al sayeh permet de monde
la joie faible 0 23eme rôti plat
s'arranger pas pour récupérer vos
facultés d'ici demain
vous pouvez faire vos bagages j'ai bien
plus fermer les yeux surtout que vos
excentricités mais s'il trouve pas mon
avantage j'ai vraiment aucune et aucune
raison de vous garder à mon service a
fait un effort que diable maman je
trouve parfaitement injuste avec adèle
d'intérêt qu'est ce que ça veut dire
hier soir il s'est prolongé longtemps
votre tête à tête poison tu le sais que
c'est un situation solange si tu as
quelque chose à dire 10 le il est je
vais m non vous solange lutter couteau
antoine couche avec la bonne là je reste
mais alors et moi qu'est ce que je fais
vous pouvez les voir s'est fait comme ça
rien de mieux que sa rivale
mais papa j'espère que tu crois pas une
seule minute cet ignoble calomnie mais
est ce que tu nous prends pour une
idiote je t'interdis cette conversation
j'ai mon mot à dire que je sache auteur
a son mot à dire que je sache a pas fait
la terre une est là cette nuit quand je
vous ai laissés seuls tous les deux qui
a poussé le verrou de la porte de ma
chambre oui qu'à pousser le verrou de la
porte de sa chambre
je sais pas moi à le verrou été poussé
vers rodez vous savez vous vite et j'ai
regardé par trou de la serrure à la gare
départ sous la terreur qu'est ce que tu
as vu j'aime bien l arrière jerry yell
plus du tout la lumière était éteint la
lumière et et étonne voilà qui me
rassure oui seulement il était toujours
là et qu'est ce qu'on peut bien faire à
deux dans le noir quand on parle pas oui
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire un devoir
grattant et bien oui puisque vous voulez
savoir oui j'ai passé la nuit à
répétition ouais et lose lose
elle ose le crier à la face une mère
pauvre j'avoue moi je suis fâcheusement
surpris je vous croyais une des deux
filles
non ici c'est dans la maison no voix
mangerait pas cru ça toi j'ai toute ma
manche c'est bien je suis pas très
avancées mais quand même j'ai 20 ans
alors encore dans son petit costume à
toi tu me verras c'est une des grandes
lois de la nature
je pensais que ça url [ __ ] possible
mais non je comprends tout que tu
comprends toi sa défaillance séquelles
des feuilles mais oui j'ai pas fait le
rapprochement
c'est clair comme de l'eau droite bien
sûr vous êtes sûr que c'est la première
fois à ne jamais jamais grâce à ça
m'était jamais venu à l'idée
oui enfin il ya bien des garçons qui ont
dû tourner autour de vous ah oui mais
vous pensez
je leur prépare un monde ont avec mandon
mdd qui sont qui peut plus vous mentir
et ce débit qu'à travailler toi te
félicite mais vraisemblable en effet que
cette extraordinaire faculté at elle l'a
perdu avec ce 10e minute misérable
misérable elle était en veilleuse en
état d'hypnose
il a fallu tout la réveille à l'avenir
je ferai bien l'attention à l'avenir en
tout cas pas chez moi et pas avec cette
fille je veux que la portanelle quoi
mais moi je trouve je t'interdis la
chasse est comme ça tu n'as qu'à et ça
pour interdire les voilà voilà un beau
panel
je crois en lui il vaut mieux pour
l'intérêt de chacun que nous nous
séparions maintenant c'est pas trop tôt
si on avait compté foutu tout allez vous
me dire vous aimez votre chat c'est pas
c'est moi j'ai pas oui ma part et pour
impayés mais huit jours à l'effet
qu'elle voit 80 je pars avec un jeu
tellement énervé j'ai envie de crier
pourquoi pourquoi j'écris les mensonges
de cette salle boniche hockey les fait
pas encore trop tard à l'eau à l'aube il
faut ajouter un kiff oui j'ai une très
bonne nouvelle pour vous figurez vous
que j'ai pris sur moi d'annoncer à mes
paroles aux fiançailles
voilà vous êtes vous heureux
le falloir aller à vélo pour le divorce
mais qu'elle divorce
vous vous êtes mariés et fous qu'ils
paient toujours d'avoir des enfants
avaient déjà pour
mais [ __ ] mais qu'est ce que la nature
de triage de l'arrivée pour ce lancement
terre elle avait raison
adele a toujours raison voyez comme nous
est pas juste avec moi tu me reprocher a
gardés chez moi après ce qu'elle a fait
dans la pauvreté s'est passé cette nuit
non mais tu plais ça manquerait plus que
ça par exemple minutes at-elle je vous
laisserai jamais partir comme ça adèle
je vous épouser quoi j'espère reproduire
comme monfils plaisant mais là non je
présente pas du tout mais si vous n'êtes
pas contents se passera de votre accord
il n'a même pas été capable de passer
sur bâche me paraît tout cela vole sa
fille des drapeaux vêtus dressait je
commence par tous supprimés pour
l'argent de poche du salut qu'au début
mais je m'en fous j'ai ma trompette
bouchée elle nourrira bien tous les deux
pas trop peut être
si t'es trompé douchez taco bell on peut
s'attendre à coucher
donc ça va mettre un terme à cette le
bouche à nourrir ses coûts seraient à
ben oui quand à vous traînerez devant
les tribunaux pour détournement de
mineure bassoues tout en les préparant
chaud enfin je détruirai les préjugés de
classe du lot avec des idées pas réduire
à loin
quant à vous avoir déposé mon fils va
vous me passez sur le coup on voit
calmez vous calmez vous j'en veux pas de
votre fils la belle à monsieur en panne
ou vous faites bien de l'honneur en me
demande en mariage mais chute à saper
derrière par terre audel oui ça va mieux
la famille vous respirez oui je te suis
pas des quads elle vous pensez qu'elle
voulait lever 1 arrive très peu pour moi
bouffard gueule mais ben oui il est bien
gentil route il est annoncé pour son âme
aintenant comment ouvert les yeux me
voir du paysage
en voyage alors là d'elle on peut dire
que vous êtes ainsi faut reconnaître que
la classe quoi alors vous partez pour de
bourg et comin corps bas tout de suite
attendez attendez ardennes avant de
partir je vous fais un petit catumbela
mais aussi à des jeux ou faire une
surprise que renard qui perd ses poils
alves
on les laisse tomber de naturellement
s'écriait teint servance bas delmas plus
qu'à vous souhaiter bonne chance
cette passe est de classe on se reverra
ses propos du temps qu'est ce que vous
allez faire ma planche et fier je me
mettais à bir extralucide mademoiselle
chanel voit et entend tout et je croyais
que vous aviez perdu voulons maintenant
que je vois plus rien juste qu'il faut
dire aux gens risquent plus de 30 ans il
vous plait ces petits poudrier boussole
et oiseaux
alors vous êtes contents des quotas
avec ça on a chois la traite de con à
froid ça fait distinguer au qu'est ce
qu'il ya parce qu'elle a essayé de
tourner mais c'est la joie certaine
qu'est ce qui ne va pas dit ça y est ça
y est il y à des lillois
ça y est je re d'état choses
extraordinaires pour la famille le
terrain de j -p total d'émissions ne
fais toi jane est partout de cela je
rencontre son premier mariage à un
satané premier est construit jusque là
c'est aussi bocal de la soirée commence
où les ou deux dernières
on avait dix ans maria chercher deux
amis antoine à devenir le plus grand
chez blackmont du monde net benny
goodman s'amène la trompette bouchée
mais cette fois je vois je vois des
fenêtres sur des ordinaires après
pendant 60 ans abel
il n'y a pas un mot de frais dans ce que
vous dites non tout peut arriver
alors à quoi rime cette comédie à vous
montrer comme un manche et il faut
donner à chacun sa part de rêve
je suis une donnée d'illusions après je
rappelle comment vous remercieront pas
partir sans nous laisser votre ordre et
la thèse ne l'est pas nous laisser
tomber que deviendrions-nous sens à
chaque fois que je travaillerai ma
trompette je penserai à vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà non je passe c'est le cas de dire
quand je pense qu'il va falloir chercher
une nouvelle bonne c'est vrai sa maman
pendant un valet de chambre avec des
yeux noisette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la pièce que nous avons joué devant vous
et de barillet et grédy
[Applaudissements]
les décors sont deux rangées art
maryse un seul de jean le poulain
[Applaudissements]
les costumes jacqueline cormier
avec mr gonon
[Musique]
c'est al ahmadi
[Applaudissements]
jean marsan
avec tapas
emma revient pas comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]